this is a story that there was not a lot
of coverage of but it is very disturbing
an anti-vaccine
anti-gay street preacher has reportedly
killed his own wife because god told him
to this is a wacky
wacky story
an anti-vaccine street preacher
has been arrested for allegedly killing
his own wife and allegedly admitting it
so there's not too much doubt here but
we're still being legally careful
the victim is a 25 year old kansas woman
named regan marek she previously played
goalie for the kansas university women's
soccer team at the time her name was
regan gibbs on the team roster her
husband is 26 year old chad merrick
suggesting merrick is her married last
name according to police chad merrick
called 9-1-1 on himself
after this incident the wife was dead
when emergency crews arrived tragic and
disturbing story
the suspect was one of these street
preachers who get a bullhorn and they do
religious stuff in populated areas and
talk about jesus he would also post
videos online which i'm not going to be
playing today and in those videos he
would attack covet vaccines as spreading
the spirit of the antichrist he would
warn people that they are coming from
your children who is the they well he
would also warn that the lgbtq agenda is
coming for your children so seemingly
that's what he means he allegedly told
police
god told him
to kill his wife
quote from fox 4's cheray honeycut he
called police and said he has killed his
wife did he possibly say why he may have
done that
and a police representative said quote
he told us
that god told him to do it so this is
one of those cases where you know when
we talk about the uh
the buffalo shooter from now close to
roughly two weeks ago a week and a half
ago
um
the right very quickly jumped to
this is just a mentally ill person
completely disconnected from politics in
all ways just there's nothing political
here
doesn't pass the sniff test we look at
the manifesto from the buffalo shooter
and we see that it's cogent fascism
it is very much
a seemingly coherently
parroting and mirroring
the substance of the great replacement
theory etc stuff that we've seen
parroted by people like tucker carlson
on fox news and others
and yes to some degree we can also say
well most mentally ill people never
commit violence
and lots of people believe things that
are wrong there's an additional element
here
which certainly um could be a factor
nobody's denying that but we can't
ignore the very real kind of political
basis for the crime at least in terms of
the beliefs
in this case
this was an anti-vaxx pastor preacher i
guess preacher is the right word an
anti-gay preacher etc
but it seems very secondary to this
particular crime god told me to kill my
own wife
this case to create a contrast is the
point
it seems way more plausible to say the
main thing here
was some form of mental illness now of
course it's we're diagnosing from a
distance or not really not really
diagnosing but we're evaluating and
speculating from a distance in both
cases we would need to know more and
have more first-hand knowledge but the
point here is to say
when we cover up an incident by saying
it's only mental illness
we often intuitively say it doesn't
really make sense here these are the
perfect contrasts when we say well
mental illness for the buffalo shooter
very specific politically charged and
cogent manifesto
mental illness there has a very
obviously different meaning than in this
particular case where a guy allegedly
killed his wife because god told him to
not saying that there aren't multiple
factors to all of these stories but it
should at least allow us to see
how different the meaning of mental
illness can or might be in different
stories let me know if you agree with
the distinction i'm drawing here
uh in what are admittedly
tragic events
and very complicated events to
understand let me know your thoughts
we'll take a quick break and be right
back